in this video I want to talk a little
bit about telomeres and telomerase and
this is happening in eukaryotes so
what's going on if we imagine that we
have a DNA strand this was the original
strand this gray strand and this newly
synthesized strand has this RNA primer
here in red and the elongated portion in
blue being the DNA so now in eukaryotes
the two enzymes Len which is a nucleus
and RNAs h go through and remove the
primer so if they go through and they
get rid of this right let's just imagine
that for a second if they go through and
they get rid of this notice what happens
this portion this portion here this DNA
here is not copied correctly right we're
missing DNA right because if we get rid
of that RNA we're missing DNA would this
be a problem the answer is yes because
what if this portion right what if this
portion here that we're missing what if
that um was coding DNA and we could have
lost it that means that could have coded
for a particular gene and that suddenly
that gene cannot be transcribed or
translated into the gene product that's
a problem
so how was this problem solved well what
happens is the the 5 prime to 3 prime
end right this is the original strand
this gray portion here what happens is
the 3 prime end is extended so this
green portion is this is added here and
this portion is called a telomere now
with the 2
is just a bunch of non-coding DNA just a
bunch of junk DNA so why is that useful
well because now the primer will be
added here and the DNA will be elongated
okay so now when these guys go in go
through and get rid of the primer
well now we're missing this portion here
but what are you missing we're only
missing this part here which is part of
the junk DNA so we don't lose any of
this precious coding DNA here right
that's important so telomeres prevent
this problem from occurring prevents us
from losing it prevents the loss of
coding DNA so what adds this - let me
hear a particular enzyme does that
that's called telomerase telomerase is a
protein and actually contains some RNA
and in the protein itself and that RNA
is that so the telomere should be the
top telomerase RNA is used as the
template to make this DNA so how is this
DNA made here
well the telomerase uses RNA that it
contains as a template to make this
telomere here so it's making DNA from
RNA right so that process was actually
an exception to the central dogma this
is reverse transcription transcription
is the process in which we take DNA and
go to RNA but now we're making DNA from
RNA so we're going backwards this is
reverse transcription so this is an
exception to the rule this of the
central dogma
so to Lemieux's basically help us
prevent the loss of important coding DNA
so to lemierre's are very very important
the length of these two lemierre's is
related to aging I'm not exactly sure
how but I hope that video overall was
helpful in understanding a little bit
more about telomeres and telomerase one
last thing I am a tutor if you live in
Southern California feel free to contact
me via email at which University at
gmail.com see the description below for
more details thank you for watching